des militants sont venus devant la
préfecture de cergy défendre les terres
fertiles de gonesse 280 hectares qui
sont situés dans le val d'oise
un combat qui dure depuis plus de 10 ans
avec la présence aujourd'hui des élus la
france insoumise europe ecologie les
verts encore le npa ou génération à
l'origine un méga centre commercial
devait être construit sur ses terres
agricoles mais à la suite de fortes
mobilisations
le gouvernement avait abandonné le
projet abandonné certes mais par refuser
son urbanisation et la construction
d'une gare en plein champ est prévue
ceux ci mobilise à nouveau les militants
jour vous d'écouter bernard loup le
président du collectif pour le triangle
de gonesse ainsi que paul vannier chef
de file insoumis pour les régionales on
attend toujours la décision du
gouvernement
tous les éléments sont connus on l'a dit
c'est pas le l'instruction de la zad qui
règle le problème ce n'est pas une
solution mais c'est au gouvernement de
décider
on attend cette décision comme on a
toujours dire la suite du rapport de
francis rol-tanguy pour les actions bien
évidemment continueront la mobilisation
est encore plus forte après le la
destruction de l'avant au fond ce combat
c'est aussi défendre la région les
franciliens de leur présidente actuelle
de valérie pécresse qui a engagé des
moyens considérables pour réprimer la
mobilisation citoyenne en défense de ses
terres agricoles qui espère par les
tribunaux par la police régler cette
question qui est une grande question
politique au fond quel est l'avenir que
nous voulons pour l'île de france
est ce que nous voulons le bétonnage
satisfaire l'intérêt des grandes
entreprises et des spéculateurs c'est ce
que propose valérie pécresse
ou est ce que nous voulons répondre aux
grands enjeux écologiques aux grands
enjeux sociaux répondre aux besoins des
habitants de l'île de france et du val
d'oise en transport du quotidien c'est
ce que nous proposons avec les monty
notin face à l'absence de réponse du
gouvernement et la prévision de la
construction d'une gare et bien les
militants s'étaient installés en zad
zone à défendre le 7 février sur ses
terres agricoles se sont fait évacuer
quelques jours par les crs mais la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas aujourd'hui
à cergy et demain à paris pour que
l'état s'engage à préserver ses terres
agricoles francilienne